yeah this is going to go down as one of
the best action movies of all time and
honestly this is probably the best
action franchise of all time given how
consistently magnificent each one of the
John Wick movies have been but somehow
this fourth installment blows the rest
out of the water you know how in the
last movie where in the Continental
Hotel John Wick and the staff have to
fight an army of high table Soldiers
with bulletproof armor which essentially
acts as a major climax of that film well
in John Wick 4 that's the level the
action starts at and it keeps getting
raised from there like someone doing the
salmon ladder jump in Ninja Warrior each
consecutive scene elevates the action
and either gives some cool variation in
either the physical aspect or something
visually spectacular is happening on
screen to make up for the fact that John
Wick isn't doing constant 360 no scopes
while running around in Paris because
that's essentially the last 30 minutes
of the movie it's a constant marathon of
outstanding action that offers unique
elements in each set piece it kind of
reminds me of Jackie Chan films where
every action scene uses the environment
in some creative way and in John Wick 4
almost every scene has a fun angle it
plays with whether it being Jon fighting
people in the middle of busy traffic
fighting on a massive staircase where
people are rolling down endless flights
of stairs or picking up a gun that
shoots flammable rounds John Wick
doesn't necessarily interact with the
environment as much as Jackie Chan does
but the setting in which the action
takes place keeps everything fresh and
exciting making it to where the
choreographers are always having a field
day in how John Wick dispatches his foes
another great thing is that the enemies
here mostly have bulletproof suits so it
makes them much harder to overcome for
Jon in the earlier movies it became a
bit annoying how easy it was for Jon to
clear rooms full of people now that
isn't an issue because each foe he faces
feels like a major obstacle so the main
solution to killing these enemies is
getting creative with up close combats
even though John Wick is supposed to be
the deadliest assassin he's still being
pushed to his limits here meaning that
the conflict he has to overcome is that
much better than the prior movies they
also made it to where John is not able
to execute constant headshots so it's
nice he's a bit more realistic in terms
of what he can achieve in the first
couple of movies him running into a room
instantly killing everyone started to
become stale to a degree because it
lacked that hard Conflict for Jon so
every scene in John Wick 4 isn't
hindered by that fact and tests him and
even though some enemies don't have
bulletproof armor they'll still throw
dozens of people at John at a time or
introduce some other elements to spice
up the scene like an example being
people trying to run over Jon with cars
action of this caliber is extremely rare
and is the utter peak of what the genre
has to offer in my opinion this is a
gold standard for high budget action
actually on the topic of budget it's
crazy to me that John Wick 4 has a
budget of 100 million dollars and other
action movies are significantly more
expensive and are worse as an example a
recent bad action movie I saw was The
Gray Man rocking a budget of 200 million
dollars so the fact that John Wick 4 has
half the budget and is infinitely better
is funny to me kind of goes to show that
practical and realistic action will
always Trump VFX Mayhem if this film
doesn't satisfy you then I don't know
what action movie will because even the
First Act of the movie basically has one
massive uninterrupted action scene that
felt like it lasted for over 30 minutes
it just floors you right out of the gate
and if you think it can't get better it
somehow does one complaint that I assume
May bug some people is that the movie is
three hours long and personally I think
it earns that run time action takes up
the bulk of the screen time and it makes
the movie feel like it's two hours long
Chad saleski said that the original cut
was almost four hours and I'd honestly
love to see that as a director's cut or
something John Wick 4 has quite a bit of
scenes dedicated to story and character
development and I think they did a great
job with them and compared person to the
last couple of John Wick movies because
for the last two they set up some silly
Notions within the world like
practically everyone on the streets
being assassins and the weird desert
scene where Jon has to find the Elder in
John Wick 4 Everything feels more
straightforward and there's never a
moment in which I'm scratching my head
because of some weird writing decisions
the movie doesn't retcon to anything so
these past writing choices are still
present but everything that's introduced
going forward is good and plausible for
the world like a lot of new high table
information is established in this movie
and I just found it all really
fascinating the characters were all
interesting and were very complex with
varying motivations they had cool
Dynamics and seeing them Clash on screen
were some of the best fights so far like
Donnie Yen's characters John's friends
but is essentially forced into a
position where he has to hunt him down
for the high table but the entire time
while doing so they have this layer of
respect for each other Donna yen is also
blind in the movie and that offers a
cool perspective in terms of action it's
kind of crazy how he's able to dispatch
the people with this hindrance and he's
basically Daredevil but as Donnie Yen
going back to the fact that John Wick is
constantly being tested seeing danian's
character overcome his conflict and
fights is also great a blind Downy Yen
rolling people would be price of
admission alone for me let alone
everything else the movie offers then
the other new Assassin character has
some cool weapons he uses throughout the
movie while also having a loyal dog that
helps him in combat at each point in the
story he has a fun Dynamic with one of
the characters and his relationship with
Bill Skarsgard was really funny so in
comparison to some of the other
assassins in the earlier films this
roster is more varied and fun all around
along with them having a more consistent
presence within the plot so it makes
them more relevant and they're able to
have character arcs throughout the story
instead of being an assassin who shows
up to fight Jon and not being it the
effort being put forward by the writers
for this movie feels like an upgrade
overall the stake's intention feels
extremely palpable in every scene and
the scenarios they concoct are genius to
me an example of that is making it to
where John has to fight through Paris
under a strict time constraints it just
made the ending feel like an incredible
rush and it really gets your adrenaline
pumping even the dialogue scenes are
injected with suspense like there's a
lot of posturing between the characters
and you never really know how they'll
interact given their complex histories
it makes them that much more engaging to
watch because there's so much subtext to
be mined from each character the writers
don't flat out tell you their
backstories and it's fun to infer from
the subtle information we are given as
to what happened in the past so the
writers are able to make even the
dialogue scenes good and this paired
with a solid Pace makes the movie feel
like a great three hours and from this
better writing I think they have the
best villain in Bill Skarsgard his
accent was a little annoying to me but
he was very menacing despite not
particularly being physically powerful
bill has a way of getting under your
skin with his unsettling Vibes and as
one of the most powerful men in the
world he slays it that and he's also
dressed in some insane drip so visually
he's a tour de force the overall cast is
just stacked and I remember when they
were announcing them one by one it was
like unwrapping Christmas presents this
is literally a once in a lifetime
ensemble cast and seeing these people on
screen together was a constant Delight
Scott Adkins in particular who hasn't
had many popular roles Ridley stole his
scenes and I was kind of surprised by
that another aspect about the movie I
loved was the music it's constantly
bumping and the Final Act has this
person on a radio that broadcast out to
assassins and she keeps playing some fun
songs that carry over into the action
scenes it really energizes the last act
and even other scenes like the club
scene has a loud booming music that puts
you into a loving trance for the
spectacle on screen really every aspect
of this movie is Brilliance and I will
kind of be disappointed if the
cinematographer doesn't get any award
recognition because this movie is
gorgeous the trailers as you can see
have some incredible shots but the
entire movie carries on with these
onspiring visuals the colors in every
frame pop and are contrasted so well
like just a random example outside of
the action is Jon standing around in
Japan silhouetted by some cool backdrops
the director and cinematographer picked
some great locations to film and every
set piece is visual eye candy just like
the last movies too honestly John Wick 4
also has one of my favorite Runners of
all time like when the winner started I
immediately leaned forward in my seat
and started uncontrollably smiling from
how amazing it was John Wick running
around eviscerating people with
flammable rounds and a winner is truly
just Peak Cinema the people in my
theater were losing their [__] in almost
every scene and you should really see
this with your friends if they
appreciate action I haven't had this
much fun in an action movie since
probably Mad Max Fury Road I'd be
surprised if John Wick 4 is able to
receive the same respect as that movie
because Fury Road got nominated for best
picture but okay we'll see it's only
like this will probably be the best
action movie you'll see in the next five
years or so I'm also going to go see
John Wick 4 again which is rare for me
especially considering it's a three hour
movie and I'm really excited to see how
the Ananda armis movie ballerina will be
thank you for watching and let me know
in the comments what you thought about
John Wick 4.
foreign